ufos und aliens geht sind die 1 gleich
raus spielerei alles blödsinn bei
anderen dagegen läuft gleich ein film ab
springt die fantasie an und spätestens
seit sich jetzt sogar der amerikanische
kongress mit einem ganz konkreten ufo
papier beschäftigte bekommt diese
fantasie neue nahrung die frage ist nur
haben wir schon einen
sensationellen beweis
oder handelt es sich um eine geniale
fälschung
licht genomik wetterballons
extraterrestrische erscheinungen immer
wieder ufo-sichtungen
wenn selbst das pentagon videos von
sichtungen veröffentlicht muss doch was
dran sein am ufer mythos dieses dokument
soll sie angeblich enthüllen die ganze
wahrheit ich sagte ich würde gern etwas
erfahren über ihr abgestürztes ufo
programm nur einer der kernsätze des
mysteriösen vilsen davis nemos ein 15
seitiges ufo papier welches selbst im us
kongress für aufsehen und wilde
diskussionen sorgt
kennen sie ein dokument welches 2009/10
auftaucht so dass wilson davis mmm mmm
nein ist mir nicht bekannt und ich kenne
das auch nicht herr vorsitzender ich
würde gern dieses dokument einreichen
und der wunsch stattgegeben
bei dem sogenannten wissen davis memo
soll es sich um die mitschrift eines
gespräches handeln das im jahr 2002
zwischen dem zwischen einem
geheimdienstchef und einem us
astrophysiker stattgefunden haben soll
in diesem gespräch soll es um geheime
forschungsprogramme der usa gegangen
sein deren inhalt es ist abgestürzte
wrackteile zu untersuchen
immer wieder die legende um den uhu
crash in roswell
1974 soll es in der us kleinstadt in new
mexico abgestürzt das später
veröffentlichte video einer alien
autopsie wird erst 1995
48 jahre später als fälschung enttarnt
doch was ist mit dem ominösen draht teil
top secret verwahrt in der militärbasis
area fifty one tief in der wüste nevadas
den wallfahrtsort eines jeden alien fans
also zum einen gibt es mehrere
militärangehörige und auch polizisten
die behaupten zeugen des damaligen
angeblichen ufo abschlusses in rossel
gewesen zu sein und es ist tatsächlich
auch so dass der
standort professor gary knowles
ein bekannter
die nun biologe öffentlich behauptet von
der cia beauftragt worden sie seien
teile zu untersuchen die möglicherweise
von uferstadt
dass wilson davis nemo feiert eu fragt
debatte neu an ex geheimdienstchef
thomas wilson bestreitet jemals eine
solche unterhaltung geführt zu haben ex
nasa mitarbeiter dr eric davis hat weder
bestätigt noch geleugnet beruft sich
stattdessen auf die geheimhaltung
experten sagen dass die details die in
diesem dokument stehen und auch die die
hintergründe und die namen die dort
genannt werden so detailliert sind
das ist recht aufwändig gewesen wäre so
ein dokument zu fälschen wenn es sich um
eine fälschung handelt dann muss man
auch die frage stellen warum fällt die
man so ein dokument und wie kommt es
dann am ende dazu dass sogar der us
kongress darüber spricht
authentischer beweis oder gut gefälscht
die antwort ist irgendwo da draußen in
den sternen
schöner ist das niemals richtige beweise
gibt kann man immer und ewig über dieses
thema reden